what do you think of the the title fight
deal Joker and and Eddie yeah I hope
Betty got you know I'd someone please
shut this dude up heat last night he was
I was gonna get on the on the on the
horn and start getting after my decide
not to because you talk about him not
people want to take vice he 22 times I
had the obligation to fight him and he
turned down took the easier fight so who
Connor yeah Connor when he find Diaz for
the first time I was flying I just
thought so I was Sunday flying home Dana
calls me and asked me if I'd if I'd to
fight Connor and that was for the DEA's
first fight and he declined me and took
Diaz on cuz Diaz was in Mexico you know
took the fight on 10 days notice
whatever but why would you want to fight
me coming off a win so yeah my name is
in the Hat and Connor and his people
didn't pick me so so you get annoyed
when stuff like that happens like you
said I get annoyed when he wants to talk
about he's the best in the world ball
fight any bill on then when it comes
time like there's a lot of that people
don't know about right behind the scenes
stuff but I know I knew what you he's
like yeah no no no so as we were trying
and I didn't even want to negotiate more
money I said [ __ ] you let's go I'll
fight you for whatever so wasn't even
about the money that time it was just
about he's running his mouth about being
the best yeah and this dude same thing
like last night he's good at when
cameras are on talking [ __ ] him in the
back he you don't say nothing really
I'll [ __ ] oh hey I've been in the
back many times then you date that this
shitty doing here I wish a [ __ ]
would behind the thing and occurred oh
man yeah so and Eddie and you beaten
Eddie right right I'm stuff I hope Eddie
uh I hope Eddie goes out there and does
the gets to win for sure you know I'm
rooting for him I wish I had this fight
this fight I was lobbying for the Eddie
fight but hey it makes more sense for so
a lot of people say getting the corner
fight that's the money like you hear the
people on the internet that's the money
but he's the money fight it doesn't work
like that I'm obligated under contract
to make X amount of dollars no matter
who I fight unless you're a champion
which eddie is because if you're a
champion then you get the pay-per-view
dollars so pay-per-view dollars if
anywhere to fight me probably not as
many paper does it bring conference
that's smart fight for for Eddie 1000%
not to pick me the pic I understand
so yeah the people also you need to take
that corner fight that's what money is
like not doesn't work like that you guys
I wish we should did